[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are featuring Emily Leigh today honey
yeah good to be here I'm really excited
to talk you have eight years of
one-on-one experience of working with
clients and have been doing a return to
sacred for two years now tell us a bit
about return to sacred we'd love to
learn about it so return to sacred is my
practice where I see clients one-on-one
I also offer guided meditations in
person and two-day trainings as well as
different trainings all through an
authentic lineage in a mystery school
and this is a lineage of King Solomon
and this mystery school helps people
shift their consciousness all while
using these keys that are passed down
through oral tradition for 3,000 years
yeah so I'm quite often referencing to
young people like especially 25 year
olds that there are things have been
passed down by humans for thousands of
years that are just really important to
understand things like meditation yes
just observing your own respiration and
feeling what you feel it helps you know
thyself helps you manage your stress and
your anxiety and all these other
important aspects of this so what else
are in these feasts of King Solomon what
what is that teacher selecting Solomon
three thousand year teachings and so
mystery school is his oldest time but
there's written documentation since King
Solomon's time who consolidated the
mystery schools into seven so there's
seven ancient mystery schools on the
planet right now and
one in which I was initiated into and
the mystery school that I initiate
others into is the only ones open to the
public right now and this mystery school
the focus is deal with the shift
consciousness to serve others and to
raise the vibration on the planet the
biggest piece with the mister school
that really drew me in was learning to
be in your joy and if that is your
baseline how can you just let go of the
layers unravel those layers that really
isn't you to come back to yourself and
that's all about knowing thyself and
meditation is one of the most important
tools to be able to shift your your
state mm-hmm okay there's seven mystery
schools and there's one of the mystery
schools is public mmm-hmm where is the
mystery school what is it called yeah so
there's a mystery school on every
continent this is in North America the
mystery is called modern mystery school
and the other mystery schools you
wouldn't be able to find these mystery
schools have I've always been private to
maintain its purity and we hit a shift
in tonight 1997 so it's been open for a
little longer than 20 years and this is
a big important milestone in terms of
mystery school because it's never been
open for this long what do you learn at
modern mystery school modern mystery
school I learn about really Who I am in
terms of beyond personality beyond
different parts of me that I labeled as
this is me and this is my purpose it's
going much deeper into Who I am and in a
spiritual sense but also just as this
eternal being of you know what are these
qualities that I'm here to share and
being able to get over a lot of the
self-sabotage so in a very practical way
it has allowed me to go beyond certain
limitations that was blocking me and my
success and in relationships and work
so this is something that's like a good
dessert that I'd like to share is what I
say okay and so you've now what she went
to a mystery school and then post a
mystery school you've been doing the
one-on-one client yes
being able to see clients one of the
things that you taught me that you're
focused on is burnout yes okay this
seems to be a roaring problem in Silicon
Valley especially yeah people are like
identifying themselves as what they're
making to like to their idea that
they're making to such an extent that
they don't have any capacity to even
realize that that's going on and that
they need to go to the beach or they
need to go to the woods you need to go
do something that's like not really
difficult to the work what is going on
and like how are you helping people sure
so speaking in terms of science that we
know about the brain is that most of us
are operating from beta beta brainwave
the mind is moving very quickly this is
usually when we're super focused on
something or working out but often we're
on the computer we're going to be in a
beta brainwave and when we're in that
state for too long
anxiety and depression starts to occur
and that's a huge on our planet right
now there's my people who feel anxious
every day when they wake up and there
never seems to be enough time and
they're running out of energy vitality
really and so they're not the when
someone is in the state of burnout
they're not able to make a very big
impact maybe for a short burst that
they'll get a lot of things done but
long term they're not able to leave
their legacy because they will feel a
sense of failure at some point their
their drive will drop so for me the most
important thing is to these passionate
people we all have our own genius and I
get so excited when I see people moving
forward and and putting themselves out
there but without tools and a great
foundation
usually it will be short-lived so my
goal is to help people create a
sustainable foundation to show and share
what they're here to do in this lifetime
all right so is beta brainwave what's
going on with the default mode Network
yeah most of most of humanity is just in
this state of doing so we're in a beta
brain way we're instead of doing when we
start to shift into an alpha state this
is more of the state of being and theta
we can access the subconscious mind so
you're accessing the subconscious mind
does that mean the brainwave is becoming
you're slowing down slowing down so it's
becoming a yeah so you're going from
beta which is a very active state to
alpha which is you can think of when
you're doing you ago you're going on a
meditative walk maybe tai chi chi-gong
something that's going to start to relax
you where you're more in sync with your
breath you're more in seek with your
your movements even aware of your body
because I find that some people can be
very dissociated from their body when
they're in that place of doing alpha is
that flow state that we're in and then
theta is when we're in a very deep
meditation and this is where most the
healing can occur because we're able to
unblock ourselves and really see what's
going on in a deeper way
okay so as I get deeper into maybe
meditation or get into a something
that's guiding me towards like a theta
state it enables me to maybe peel back
the layers to get to what the essence is
yeah and we might not need to be doing
as much as we think we need to we keep
ourselves really busy yeah I have a big
to-do list yeah and when I was on my
journey I realized that half of things
on my to-do list had nothing to do with
what I really needed to get done in a
day to work towards my bigger goal and
so when we're able to strip away the
things are unnecessary it gives us so
much time and freedom in space yeah so
much FOMO though
hey oh well yeah we were taught by June
Ewing about opportunity obesity yeah
yeah where's we takin so much because
we're obese with opportunity now and we
have fear of missing out on all of those
different opportunities but it's really
important to say no and to focus on
we're gonna get that in the cutoff half
of year to do this so that way you can
be more focused and have more time for
the self yeah I figure though and
sometimes a meditation as I'm letting go
there's like a grieving of like oh but I
wanted to do that or that was a really
exciting you know project that I wanted
to work on with someone and it's like oh
but no if I if I did this it's actually
a distraction and that's the thing about
the negative ego in the mind is it's
always be like oh this is a sexy option
what about this what about that and it
just takes us away from what's gonna
bring us the most joy
but it's the idea of that that project
or or that thing that we want to do that
night versus working towards something
that's more meaningful do you think
about the Emily in the parallel universe
that we know and did that project
sometimes yeah it's I feel that we are
so responsible for the life that we lead
and I hear sometimes like oh if it's
meant to be and how I see the world is
that we have lots of choice and I
sometimes like what would have been like
if I made this choice and I try to just
learn from that like oh you know this
this choice doesn't really feel like I'm
really in my full power and potential
like next time this opportunity comes
along I would do it this way and so I do
take that time to reflect Journal
meditate on it yeah and that's how I
refine thank you moving forward so when
you're meeting with clients are they
usually entrepreneurs most of them are
entrepreneurs whether they're small
business owners they have a tech company
or tech startup and some are in some
in-between space maybe they've been in
tech and they're trying to figure out
what their bigger purpose is but most of
them are entrepreneurs yes and then when
you're meeting with them would you say
that what is the number one thing that
people need help with number one thing
people need help with is focus and
direction because of what we're just
talking about is all the distractions
most people who are entrepreneurs have
so many opportunities yeah and they're
meeting so many people and there's many
ideas that they have I'll wake up with
an idea every morning there is like one
more idea like something that excites me
yeah yeah and it's helping them get more
clear and step into their next phase of
their journey so because what they do
want is is success they want to have
maybe more abundance maybe they want to
have a better relationship with their
partner or maybe their work is is like
number one and they feel second to that
I hope yeah like they don't feel like
their bodies is feeling great is that it
could and they're not eating well and
they're not really working out and
they're just like well if I keep doing
this and then eventually I'll start
working out and it's this idea in the
story so when I work with them it's
helping them get really clear about what
their true wants are and and helping
them meet their needs
as well but it's a
a shift in how we work as a society it's
very different but when they're able to
stand in that and I'm what I've seen as
a result it's it's incredible because
now I see them how some of these people
helping so many more people and having
the the energy to get the things in the
need done working towards growing their
business would you say that culture has
kicked us into overdrive yeah I mean
culture has put us in a situation and
like this prison of I'm not enough so a
lot it feeds a lot of our insecurities
of eun-joo more always there's always
something to do and there's always
something new as entrepreneurs it's like
well do you back as to you but you have
this like new website you have this T of
that are you doing all these things on
social media so we could never really
accomplish everything we're trying to
keep up yeah what are you looking at me
for
it's pretty good I think it's pretty
well said yeah could never achieve
everything all the new technological
advances that are going on and all the
ways to integrate those aspects into
what you're building and then you're
waking up in the morning with new ideas
I mean no way you can't hit me great all
that and then you barely have enough
time for your own health your own
partner or or even writing down what you
actually want
this is it's interesting I was thinking
about it when you were talking about it
and that's why I asked about culture
taking us into some sort of overdrive
mode because we think that we have to
achieve so much I think mostly because
of this kind of like hierarchy of
competence that exists and we're just
trying to climb up this hierarchy of
competence as quickly as possible in our
age because we know that it'll drive us
to a better life outcome and I just I
wonder how much of that drive is
actually important and like it's
important to go through the edge being
on the edge of burnout because then
you're constantly driven to achieve
these goals into the world in the short
time that you have versus being a little
bit more okay with being further away
from the edge and being like now those
like that to-do list of stuff tomorrow's
fine yeah so what you're describing
right there is more apathy I'm just like
doesn't matter I don't really care and
then you have someone who's an overdrive
using a lot of their adrenaline to get
something done mm-hmm we have is
in-between of someone who has their feet
on the ground and yet still has a big
vision because there's something there's
something pushing them they have a
bigger why and it's not really about
their status it's something much bigger
and when someone starts to discover
associate their meditation these
different techniques what their rise and
what they're really here to do then they
don't deserve necessarily need the
adrenaline pushing them forward but I
live on the edge every day of my comfort
zone because it's like I see the
suffering happening in the world and I'm
like that's what drives me forward yeah
and I'm like oh I can't stop because
like this is way bigger than me doesn't
mean that I'm like oh every day I'm like
cats do this like there's some days I'm
like oh I feel my resistance
and I have to check in and be like okay
well um do I do I need to like meditate
and this is just I'm gonna feel this way
while I'm doing work today or is it
because I've been working five days in a
row and I haven't really taken a break
just have fun and do something that just
brings me back to my senses so that's
what I work with on a personal level is
trying to move from vitality and
accessing that flow state more because
work what if work was a reflection of
our love and when we're feeling that
like poisonous energy like I just have
to like get this done and we're hurting
ourselves it actually doesn't create
what we want to in the world and then it
is a reflection of love mm-hmm so I try
to stop myself like oh if I even put it
putting a post out there it's like if
I'm doing this because I'm feeling
bitter like I gotta just get this stuff
done today I try to just like take a
step back and question because less it
less can really be more like minimalist
in terms of what you're doing in your
business less can be more
when you are using your tongue as a
sword and being very clear about what
you're saying and sharing a message so
I've been looking at that and seeing how
I don't need to be on social media all
the time but when I am I want my words
to be meaningful yep okay so if we get
into a state of constant love for what
we're doing it doesn't feel like apathy
doesn't feel like adrenaline it just
feels like a state of flow and then we
can maybe take a better third-person
perspective on ourselves and take time
away from what we're doing to go and
work out or eat a healthier or spend
some time with friends or family or or
go to the some aspects of nature and
just detox from digital world
and I've been that person who was I was
my business and I've had many different
businesses but when I had I had my own
yoga studio and healing center in
Providence Rhode Island back in
2013-2014 and I just worked and I was a
slave to my work and it got to a certain
point where my help was going down I
couldn't keep up with any of my
relationships and I wasn't creating even
the abundance that I could have been
creating so there was everything was
audible I'm everything fell out of
balance and out of sorts yet I was
living what I thought my bigger dream
was was having the center and it wasn't
told that moment but I was like there's
got to be a different way and I've gone
through many different I guess you call
awakening States but that was a huge
awakening state I feel like being on to
an entrepreneur is one of the most
spiritual paths because you learned so
much about yourself and how you're
serving the world
yeah I agree on tradition one of the
best things you'll ever do mm-hmm
interesting that you were in the process
of having a center and abundance and
teaching yoga and inspiring people
waking them and then even through a
practice like that it's not even a
conventional like nine-to-five behind a
desk you were still having so much
overload by your workflow yeah I was
managing a whole team of yoga teachers
staff and then I was teaching 2000
classes a week it's a lot in addition to
doing all the marketing so I could I
just took it all in I was like well I
can do it so I'm gonna do it all and
until I realized that I was getting my
own way of success yeah I had to take a
step back I'm like what is it that I
really want to do how do I really want
to use my time well I'm here what if
someone's essence is to to like be at
the edge of
here's some there's some class work
meditation that I'm teaching
it's called sanctuary meditation so this
gives people a better awareness of their
voice of their higher self versus their
negative ego and so that question that
you just asked is a great thing that I
bring into my meditations is asking
myself and sanction meditation is a way
to shift consciousness so I'm able to
tap into more of that theta brainwave
and work within my subconscious in ways
that my negative ego my my mind could
trick me so taking taking that time and
also just I am my own scientist like
I'll test things out and I'll see like
what are the fruits from this way of
being and what I saw after many years of
running around doing everything I was
scattered so when I was scattered trying
to do everything I was it was very
difficult to do one thing very well yeah
and I could I could totally do it all
but I was much more effective when I was
delegating and trusting and working with
others and I feel that our purpose is
learning how to connect and collaborate
and give other people the opportunity to
do what they're really good at as well
yeah delegation collaboration yeah
there's you I guess I want to see if we
can understand this a little better
because this is probably a really
difficult thing to get is you're
hustling you're working really hard you
think that your meaning or your purpose
here fulfillment of what you're aiming
to achieve in the world has to do so
much with what you're building and that
your health and your nature and your all
this other stuff can take a temporary
backseat to that or maybe you just don't
mind that they only constitute one or
five percent of your time versus ninety
five percent of your time being focused
on what you're building
maybe that what would if that is the
true flow for you what if that is what
your essence is everybody's gonna have a
different balance so some people are
like fifty fifty some people are yeah
everybody's got a different balance and
and some days are gonna be different
than others I would say the most
important thing is people are suffering
and they feel that the only way to have
a business is to always feel that
they're second to themselves that the
business has to come first
and so it's shifting it to seeing like
when you take care of yourself first in
a way where your body can feel amazing
you can feel connected and you start the
day where you know what it is that you
need to do for the day and you don't
feel overwhelmed and a victim of society
if like I got to do this and that there
are times when people don't even have
that awareness of that that they're
totally eating into the hustle mode and
time slipping away there's never enough
to do things are usually falling apart
and their life on some level when they
come to me that there's something there
either curious about like there's gonna
be a different way to create this
business or things are are suffering or
they're getting in their way of actually
getting to that next level because the
patterns will just keep showing up and
it's like people are trying to climb
over this wall and they
get to that next level whether it is
again more financial success or just
things that they're wanting to create
and their mind will create these blocks
when you open up these different states
of awareness solutions come much faster
so that just this idea that you have to
work really hard to be worthy of that
success that's usually in people's
belief systems is working really hard
equals success and what I've seen is for
myself and brothers you can actually
work less and succeed more that's a very
backwards way of viewing but usually
we'll do something over and over again
make mistakes
try to come to the solution then it
changes when I'm meditating I can
actually get that solution much quicker
hmm and I'm like oh that's what I got to
do okay
and it's my beeline it yeah versus try
all these other things that I hear that
yeah I hear that so there's a process
for me where if I get into a state of
like being in nature or if I get into a
state of meditation or if I just have a
day where I'm not blocked off all day
and my calendar when I'm just free
sometimes I come up with these
epiphanies that I can be lined towards
yeah and that actually helps a lot cuz
if your calendars filled with stuff you
don't have the free time to be able to
ponder an epiphany but also the things
that we usually fill our calendar with
sometimes actually don't provide us with
the fastest path to what we need yeah
it's that romanticizing busyness it's
like oh I'm busy and so we feel like
we're on track we feel like we're in
alignment we're doing a great job and
we're doing our best but we may not be
fulfilled you may not have that at the
end of the day that happy tired feeling
of like like I used up all my resources
and the best way like I love going to
bed happy tired
and feeling the guy I did last night
yeah slow two hours I went a bit happy
tire yeah cuz I have done a really good
amount of work and I felt great but also
at the same time like Matthew Walker
would be killing me right now why we
sleep he'd be killing me he'd be like
who's Matthew Walker sleep scientists
from Berkeley be killing me right now
just because he's he did so much
research and work on the human need for
eight hours of sleep because I'm just
I'm not I'm not as not as a week as I
could be today I'm not as I haven't I
haven't saved as many of the wired as
many of the neural connections in my
mind as I could have from the day before
there's there's lots of things and I
just I can't if everybody has a
different balance for figuring out how
much time they want to invest in
themselves and in their business and so
most people even put their business
before themselves then if it's a
different balance for everybody this
makes a very complicated equation a
complicated process so one of the first
things you have to do is you have to
figure out what you're walking but your
needs are yeah I have the question yes
is it possible to return to sacred but
still be someone on a darker side of
life I'm darker Salus so yeah I mean is
sacred isn't necessarily the light yeah
no well I think there's like two
questions here so one question you had
was every has a different balance so the
first I'm going to say to that is that
yes and that's why it's so hard for
people to find the answers through
podcasts and even this video right now
like I can't say like what someone's
answer is and know thyself is what the
true goal of mystery school is is to
know who you are and know what your
needs are one
the most frustrating things when I was
on my path going through this lineage
and the spiritual pathway was that there
wasn't any teacher be these
international teachers amazing they were
tapped in and I'd want the answers like
tell me what to do and they went just
like no empower me to figure it out for
yourself
and so that's an empowerment really is
is about using the tools taking taking
the risk of trying different things out
and figuring out what's going to really
work for you and in terms of is return
to secret about light or dark I find
that it's about returning to what's real
and returning to and we are I believe
that we are light and that way we have
this purity and this goodness and there
are things in the world that are going
on that aren't of the light there's
whether it's comes down to violence or
rape or never in sexual abuse and things
that have have hurt people and have
played into their trauma and have played
into this need you know sexual trauma
sexual abuse different kind of emotional
abuse does play into this need to
succeed and to cover up certain things
so there's lots of different things that
people Bend through and trauma is really
anytime someone hasn't wasn't able to
express themselves so it doesn't have to
be some people are like I haven't gone
through trauma and then they start to
heal and I said to work through things
like oh this thing happened in
elementary school and you know this
teacher told me to be quiet and they
were expressing something that was
really important to them so it is about
returning to our divinity it is about
returning to what's real and letting go
of the things that we associate
ourselves with that stops us from maybe
allowing ourselves to succeed maybe
allowing ourselves to take a break and
so we can use work to push ourselves
forward and find that edge but I've also
seen people use work as a way to hide
from the different things that they
don't they don't feel ready to feel but
with the one-on-one work that I do I
find that people can find more of that
grace and that ease
and when there's that space there's not
such an aggressive way to go after what
they want
there can be bringing in more of this
feminine energy that a lot of people are
trying to find how to do and how to work
with that balance of masculine and
feminine but yeah return to sacred
you're gonna work with different things
that aren't always gonna be light it's
not about rainbows and butterflies and
let's just look at the light for me it's
it's really like let's look at it let's
look at it all and not be afraid of it
so that we can you know see ourselves
know ourselves and move forward based on
what choice is gonna be best so then we
look at the one of the first things we
need to do is look at our needs and the
write down our needs so you can like
look at them and understand them again I
mean what are people's typical needs
like love yeah like air and water
obviously in shelter and stuff like that
we have basic needs and I teach this
more in the two-day as well we go deeper
into this theory but we have basic needs
that were not meeting right now
and most of it is going to be self love
this love of this this connection and a
lot of times people don't know how to
receive that connection
they weren't taught how to base to be a
schoolteacher so you know we're not
teaching this in first grade we're we're
focusing on time on learning and all the
subjects but there isn't teaching about
emotions teaching about how to meditate
I did sneak it in but that wasn't part
of the curriculum and we grow up
focusing on work and being a good little
worker bee and we get to an adult life
and something isn't working and maybe
we're looking at alternative methods or
healing or shifting where we're thinking
and that's when people start to look at
that but before that happens a lot of
times people are plugging in instead of
plugging in upward to that main source
of energy that can flow through that
vitality that Chi they're plugging into
maybe it's Netflix maybe it's drugs
maybe it's alcohol it could be
codependent relationships there's so
many ways people are plugging into all
the outlets around there
trying to find something to plug into
and then work is a huge thing that
people plug into because it does fuel
something you might get some positive
reinforcement from it so there's gonna
be something and it gives them a
connection but that connection when
you're plugging up to source and
connecting your higher-self I mean it's
it's never-ending like it's just you can
keep flowing and getting a lot of your
energy from that power versus these
other quick fixes that eventually burn
out from okay so so source what what can
you what describe source yeah because I
think what you were describing about
running around and like plugging into
Netflix or drugs or whatever codependent
relationship to the business etc we're
plugging into these things and they're
giving us temporary like relief yeah
source to me is that which is everything
and nothing it's very difficult to
describe can't describe it
but it's something that I feel I sense
when I'm in very deep sense of
meditation something I feel moving
through me when I'm serving others when
I'm in flow State and that is for you
know others to describe in their own way
what that is but source to me is is that
connection dude there's there's
something much bigger than me and yeah
but it's it's something that's not
definable you can describe it as the
universe you could mean there's many
different ways to describe it but what
I'm tapping into that it's like oh
that's what I was looking for it's like
when you walk into room you forget we
were looking for like that's kind of
what humans came into this world like
what was I looking for and then when you
start to find it like ah that's what
that's why I came into this room and
this room being this world yeah
just visiting just visiting
Ron's bio so this is bio it's a great
bio a little bit think when you plant
your feet on the ground that you can
ride some sort of energy from the earth
through your heels and up through your
body go out of your head
it's all different waste to manifest
something from the heart you mind and
make something happen through here that
we don't get at all I like to see it is
like this vertical line of energy and
when we're connected to that it can be
our source of power however a lot of
times people are operating from this
horizontal line of energy that's kind of
the outlets that you were talking yeah
so they're like plugging in and you see
all these cords and so there's
attachments those are attachments and
we're attached to other people like love
me you know we're attached to different
substances and it's like fix me help me
feel whole there's so many ways which we
attach ourselves to things and if we're
pulling from there it's it gets pretty
complicated it gets complicated
what does what what does this vertical
integration this the source this
constant tapping into the source versus
the horizontal integration of tapping
into the to the outlets that adds a lot
of complication when when we're fully
vertically sourced what is that what is
that like yeah well people say all the
time like be a vessel and to me that's
what it's like it's like allowing this
energy to move through you not getting
attached to it don't be like how can I
control this and just allowing it to
move through we will go through flow
States and they're going to be times
it's part of like part of finding
balance is
is losing it and part of feeling this
flow state is also getting distracted
and this is part of our human process
we're not gonna be in flow state in this
perfection all the time
yeah but return to sacred is also about
like how can you come back to that flow
state more quickly and not go down that
rabbit hole of self-doubt
I feel like self-doubt is huge for
entrepreneurs as well where they're
doing really well and they're in that
flow state and productivity is so
important I'm like how can I be
productive all the time we're gonna go
through different phases and it's like
also trusting those different phases
we're gonna be in flow state and other
times you need to process and when you
give yourself time to process certain
emotions and you're not shutting
yourself out you're seeing your business
as this is it's like a child it's like a
baby but even a mother needs to put
herself first you'll to take care of
that child and so when you're in that
but when you're in connecting to that
energy that source that vertical line
you're much more able to let that
radiate Reedy out and make an impact and
that's just like you're just showing up
you're in that being state and other
people can pick up on it I recently just
had actually my uber driver reach out to
me after our ride and come in first
session because I was with him for ten
minutes in the car and he's like I don't
know what it was but I just talked to
you for a little bit I could feel
something and my whole weekend was
amazing and I want to know how to do
this for myself and I was like cool
let's do this one-on-one session they
did a session called life activation
look at that it's the vertical line we
don't have any right so we have to get
rid of it right yeah and it was really
an honor to work with him because that
was you know an example of I was just
showing up and I you know just before
that ride it was kind of going into this
place of like oh I have someone should I
get done when I print these things out
way before hand beating myself up for a
little bit and then I was able to come
back which would normally take me maybe
like ow
to come back to just like okay this is
just what it is right now and I was able
to get in that uber I'd really feel full
connected to myself and had a huge
impact on this person cuz I was like can
I felt that connection to that vertical
line of energy versus maybe whirring or
putting my headphones in because I was
too tired or stressed or didn't want to
talk to someone so the way that we show
up in the world even when we're not in
that process of creating we're not
working with our business yeah it's
amazing yeah man just scratching the
surface of what this is yes why it's
also important to understand gosh I
really like the horizontal versus
vertical like integration or the source
going directly vertical with the source
versus Horizonte seems to be like we're
just plugging into things temporarily
yeah I like the horizontal one how to
stay with that till I'm done what do you
think about that the horizontal well
what do you think about people that are
okay with the horizontal like yeah if if
that works for them it's gonna work for
them maybe till a certain point until
they need maybe something else and when
they need something else that's usually
a sign that they're ready to connect and
look at that where there was a
disconnection and the biggest take home
for me is with this work and when I see
how it helps people is it a lot people
neglect themselves and they leave
themselves behind when they are going
after something like think that they
want and when they do get really clear
about their true wants it's not
necessarily a conscious like well I'm
not gonna connect horizontally it's just
like this yearning to connect to love
this yearning to just be the kind of
person they wanting to leave something
behind that's maybe more than just a
quick
something that's gonna give them some
kind of temporary satisfaction something
it's gonna actually help humanity or be
of service to someone besides themselves
but when they're in a place of
connecting horizontally it's not a
judgment but usually people are just
looking for that quick relief but it
doesn't really support other people when
they're doing that it's gonna support a
lot more people when you're connecting
that horizontal sorry vertical line of
energy interesting then it becomes the
connection to the vertical line of
energy supports oneself better as well
as other people around them and just
modeling it and embodying that I've seen
people are just like remember like oh I
want like the guy in my uber ride he's
like oh I want that too I can feel it I
want to feel that way and I in a lot of
it is nonverbal and it's just showing up
and when I was teaching yoga classes I
mean a lot of clients came from that
because they could just feel something
it wasn't necessarily something I said
in my classes when people are coming for
meditation they can feel something so
it's non conceptual which is interesting
to talk about something that's non
conceptual and doing our best to take
this abstract concept and put it into
words yeah yeah yeah well it's really
resonating with me and I think a lot of
people that experience burnout
especially like you were talking about
being at a state of beta brain waver
Sustaita brain wave and also vertical
integration reverse horizontal
integration vertical energy source
versus horizontal energy source I've I'm
wondering what your take is on you
touched on this earlier but like
codependence and like relationships like
for both business as well as intimate
what is like what's your take on that
well I know a lot about it because I
used to engage and many codependent
relation
chips ii speak from firsthand how it
stopped my progression and put me in a
box of this is the only things that i
will ever achieve in this lifetime
because i'll need other people in a way
to create this or survive a lot of it
came from survival and caused me to be
in a state of fear a lot of the time so
i had many different romantic
relationships that that were codependent
and because of that it stopped me from
maybe going further in my business and
doing things that we're gonna be a
little bit more out there and outside
the box and that really made them feel
uncomfortable but when i got to a
certain point where i was like well i'm
sorry but i'm gonna evolve past your
comfort zone that's when I became more
free and even with the work that I do
it's going to be even with some people
that I meet that want to work with me it
may not be for everybody cuz it's like
okay this is you in a lot of ways not
conventional it's not therapy it's
working with energy and working with the
energetic body and the way that we've
imprinted things in our life and going
to the root of that so yeah there's a
lot of ways if I was codependent still I
couldn't be charging forward and
speaking my truth it would really stop
me because I would be in fear and I
would need other people to give me that
permission and validation so with that
without that it's like the chains have
been cut and it's such a more freeing
experience with this way to live but it
took me it took me some time to even see
that that's what was going on thought I
thought that was love and even how I
worked with my clients like I thought
that was love but we think love is a
certain thing and so we see it as
something much it's it's not something
that's gonna enslave you it's not
something that will ever stop your
progression and how I work with clients
empowering them not giving them the
answers but helping them find the
answers and not holding on to them
sometimes if we're gonna come in there
made something and then they need to
move on and and take that and work with
something else or they just need to work
on their own and integrate on their own
and be able to hold that space for
others to whether it's me needing
someone or me trying to be there for
someone being able to have someone hold
the container for me but figure it out
or being that person that's gonna hold
space I want to make sure we get to a
couple really important question okay
one of the questions that I want to ask
you is about energy I don't think we
know anything about energy I think
humans know nothing about energy
I think women know more about energy
than men do maybe I feel that we all
understood understand the concept of
energy it is something that is being
asked to be felt all the time in terms
of our energetic body and how it shows
up and we can feel energy in many ways
you know there's many ways we can be
intuitive and use our intuition some of
us are going to hear or see or feel
feeling is how I pick up on energy and
an example of that would be what I'm
feeling excited I would get butterflies
in my stomach or I'm about to say
something that's gonna be difficult
feeling my throat closed up a little bit
you see you're tapping into the nuance
of your own personal feeling and I think
well there's a way let's talk to that
yeah stimulus comes in because that
energy is is is all around us and we can
also utilize that energy and we have
energy within us but yes we we aren't
using the energy that's available to us
and when we're disconnected for
especially we're in beta brain wave or
not gonna be aware of that or an alpha
weird state and we're practicing yoga
we're connecting to our breath then
we're feeling our Chi and that's so this
is how we feel the nuance within
ourselves
at a deeper level is by going to
and slowing down yeah meditating just
read something called cheeto so what I'm
engaging in these activities I can
connect to my body even in meditation I
can start to feel my body relaxed I in
the beginning of totally something
called a Maxima detection system that I
teach I have people start in their body
because we need to start with our body
before we go into these higher states
and we're holding a lot of tension not
even realizing it and I remember when I
started meditating I was like whoa I
didn't realize I didn't even realize
that I was holding all this tension my
body like here's something that I I
frequently will just I'll like will do
stuff like this I'll like what are you
doing so like when I when I when I get
up I'll get up from working at a
computer and I'll just you know I'll
just start playing around with moving my
body around like this and I already felt
a crack and creak a bunch and you know
that's how I tap in to tap into energy
in just a really quick way it doesn't
need to be meditation you use body
movement like that especially for a lot
of the tech entrepreneurs are watching
ya sitting at your desk and and being on
the computer really if you're an
entrepreneur and most the time you're
it's a lot of the planning before you do
the execution and you're can be so in it
and forget about your breathing forget
about your body yeah and so your breath
your just even if you can't live you're
on an airplane you're sitting for a long
time just the practice of feeling your
breath and working on different breath
exercises and techniques and when I was
a school teacher and I had kids sitting
in their seats for hours which is just
like not like doesn't seem normal at all
but you know you had like these first
graders sitting for
time we do different feeling exercises
and sometimes we would just stand up and
do like one yoga pose so yeah you don't
have to do like a whole yoga practice or
go to tai chi class or chi gong it's
it's warm just can you give yourself
that those breaks to reconnect yes so
that you're not again forgetting or
neglecting yourself in the day it's
great great way to put it
do you think that consciousness is
localized in this nervous system or what
do you think about the
multidimensionality of the being yeah
well I feel that it's beyond
conceptualizing in our mind and that's
why meditation is so powerful because we
can start to tap in that it's just it's
beyond our body this consciousness is
beyond this physical body what do you
feel when you go beyond the body with
meditation where do you go what is it
like what do you feel like so when I
have accessed these deeper states of
meditation it feels like my whole body
is taking up the entire room and I'm
much more expansive when I come back I
can still feel that expansiveness I
still feel like I can take up like a
whole space if I wanted to but I'm like
much more beyond just this what I'm
seeing what I'm feeling so I feel that
our consciousness isn't limited to time
or space and our consciousness is also
it's like Wi-Fi it's like all connected
so interesting how you know when you
think of someone and like that person
texts you right away
and how cycle it so it's like run Wi-Fi
to go thinking of this and how even like
different different people of the same
products even or they I know Elizabeth
Gilbert talks about this in big magic in
her book and that it's it's like people
will create even like the same book it's
almost like the same
birds and they live in different parts
of the world so yeah I think
consciousness is so much wider than we
can even understand that our minds
yeah the monkey minds not enough to
interpret it even if we tap into
meditation at its fullest the human mind
I think without really deep
augmentations past the meditative
ability is still limited physical we
want to quantify everything we do want
to quantify everything like how can I
prove this and prove that I think you
can't even prove source it's just it's
so much it's like even to start to try
to put words to it yeah we we limit it
right away it's like stop the flow of it
it's true
okay how about what he thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world
is someone who has no fear and they are
just in their joy well there's like a
baby laughing or just someone in like
that pure joy that's to me the most
beautiful thing I think laughter enjoy
go hand in hand
yeah there's something about laughter
laughter is like the second to deja vu
in terms of the amount of time that we
actually get to spend in it mm-hmm lake
de Chevreuse less you get even less time
spent in deja vu I just had some last
night and I was just like uh I want to
capture this I want to hold it longer
had that you know because it's just so
fascinating by and then laughter comes
you know if you're lucky you get to
laugh hysterically once a day if you're
lucky I think so
my friend sent me pretty good meme so I
have the honor of that is that the I
think that's the ticket yeah
the ticket yeah there's another good
memes through good laughter we have a ai
safety security researcher Roman yo
skee whose ridiculously funny with the
memes yeah they're like hilarious AI
robot takeover memes you know stuff like
that so I think it's gonna descend Mesa
yeah yeah you should definitely follow
them you post all the time that's a good
one so yeah so friends that are sending
funny memes we're sending it back that's
right sometimes it's about like
breakdowns or it could just be about
making fun of like us as humans and our
like emotions yeah
just like laughing at ourselves it is
nothing you're so seriously so I think
those are the ones that I'm like okay I
can laugh at this because it's so true
and it can just help me in those moments
I think comedians are very special
people very important people in many
ways but I think there's equally two
comedians is equal to like business and
all these other places that like there's
certain ones that are doing exceptional
work other ones that are like have a
little bit of a way to go including you
know ourselves so what do you think is
kind of going on in our world with
figuring out the balance between the we
are one mentality with the geopolitical
leadership with like exponential
technology and wealth inequality what do
you think's going on there in a way I
don't feel like any of us any of us have
true privilege because I mean just look
at the people who are really successful
and they have taken their lives and they
suffer from depression and anxiety and
can't even understand what's going on
their minds
damn that's a ridiculous answer I mean I
don't feel like any of us really have
privilege do you think like Jeff Bezos
is not as you think Jeff Bezos as equal
as happiness as the person that makes a
dollar a day I don't know but I've seen
some people who have very little and
they have a lot of laughter in their
life a lot of joy so they have a lot of
stress on the really wealthy side yet
yeah you can have joining the wall on
the wealthy side because that person has
figured out how to master themselves and
in the two day when I teach we talk
about the 12 physical dimensions and how
to master that when you can mass with
these 12 physical dimensions financial
abundance is is one of those but when
someone isn't utilizing it and giving
back and learning how to work with it to
fuel their purpose then it can be
daunting overwhelming it really doesn't
make a huge difference in terms of
freeing someone up to feel connected and
on the poor side of things even if
you're laughing a lot you might have it
might be malnourished yeah you might not
have your needs met so it's really
important I feel like to make a point
where with more of the people who feel
that they want to make an impact in the
world when those people have our empower
because money is this is a tool of power
when you're using that tell people meet
their needs then we can shift the
conscious collective up but first we
have to meet that we have to help us
people to meet their needs and I feel
the people who have the most heart and
the most Drive when we are being in our
place of self serving and just plugging
into Netflix playing it we can't really
help those people so instead of looking
at it as it's the people higher up it's
like how can we come into our power how
can we create that abundance and then
what we're seeing it you know those
other people are just blind maybe into
they're there in their own space they're
in their ego centric place but the
people that are waking up it's even more
of a push to yeah to help other people
waking up through the vertical source
integration and then bringing oneself to
the world and that's in that respect
yeah do you think we're alone in the
cosmos and the universe you think we're
alone here in that way no way no I I I
feel that there's so much that we can't
even fathom in our mind again our mind
is so limited to what we can feel and
sense but the more that I move forward
on my path and these undeniable
I'm having is that we are very much
supported and there's a lot of
underutilized resources of how to tap in
and yeah there and these people who've
gone through mystery school like famous
people initiates Carl Jung Lera DaVinci
William Shakespeare The Beatles David
Bowie all these different people who
were like tapped in utilizing this
energy and I feel that even after they
die it's like it's like we can utilize
these people who've left their legacy
and again that idea of time and space of
tapping into that conscious collective
but even more than that I feel that
there's there's energies that we can
bring in and call in and utilize to
manifest do you think there's a designer
to the universe well I look at the world
and it's so beautifully made and yet so
intricate in terms of the geometries and
different shapes and how everything is
created and someone would have to have
designed it I mean like I don't feel
that it is random that that
consciousness or that designer you know
and how everything is made from these
geometries and that's something that I
teach as well is sacred geometry being a
language of the universe language of God
ancient language of source and when you
start to tap into these it's like oh
there's something much bigger designing
our reality hmm
I also recently read that physicists are
too enamored with the beauty of the
geometry sacred geometry of the universe
that they are unable to really
objectively figure out theories that are
scientifically behind it I thought that
was so funny
Emily wow what a great sit down what a
great conversation yeah thank you for
coming on to our show we really
appreciate thanks for teaching us
so much you had of really good analogies
to okay yeah the analogy of like
vertical source and then like horizontal
plugging into other things instead that
was really powerful there were some
other really powerful ones I just feel
like I can better understand even just
from intellectually here and being
experienced rly here I think I can I
think hopefully we can better understand
burnout and we can better understand
tipping ourselves too close to the
adrenaline too close to the apathy but
rather being right there in that moment
to moment hopefully hopefully we you
know hopefully we can integrate this you
know this is the big things like
integrate what we learned today into our
lives experientially and we're gonna go
out there and practice these things make
it more applicable get up and move
around while we're in the middle of the
workday do a couple stretches meditate
do some breath work go to walk in the
park be like it's okay if I don't answer
emails for a couple minutes I'm gonna go
lay in the park for a bit and look at
the clouds because then you might have
the Epiphany that helps you accelerate
your business faster your your personal
life faster thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it if
you guys had a good time make sure to go
and take this content go share it with
two people go and tell them about it
have them go tell other people about it
implement these things into our lives
make our whole world just so much more
tapped into source subscribe comment
below with your thoughts we'd love to
hear from you check out the link in the
bio to return to sacred go give Emily
some love as well also thank you if you
guys had a good time also join us on
patreon we definitely need to continue
supporting the studio and growing it
making more impact so join us there
thanks around Vargus are producing
partner thank you everyone and we'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Music]